we've talked about elton john before
saying you know hey you billy you should
write more songs you say it just left
you it just it's something you didn't
want to do anymore you have to want to
you have to have the desire
to write songs i love music so i never
stopped writing music
right it's instrumental music but i
stopped writing lyrics because
i got tired of that particular format to
me music is enough now
i became more comfortable with abstract
form
uh so hearing music
does it for me it satisfies me but if i
have an idea for a song i'm not going to
stop myself i just haven't had the
desire to do it you know sometimes like
with new york state of mind you say you
came to you in 20 minutes it was like a
gift like boom you're sitting on a bus
and 20 minutes there it is but it sounds
like most of the time
it is a aggravating
puzzle that you constantly have to
figure out even you've done it before
and you've written hit songs i gotta go
back and it's like starting all over
again and that's the frustration
yeah it can be a grind uh sometimes
i look at the piano and it's this big
black beast with 88 teeth that wants to
bite my fingers off
and i go and i try and i please help me
something
and you get you come up with nothing
it's the most
frustrating feeling in the world because
you want to be productive you want to
create something and it doesn't always
come to you like a bolt out of the blue
it's you don't always get that
promethean moment like i did with new
york state of mind
um
and
the
the worst thing about songwriting is the
struggle i love having written i hate
writing i realize so much of your music
is about real life and like like even
like when you the years you sat in a bar
and played and you got to observe people
and and write about them you become so
successful
and by necessity reclusive that you
don't interact the same way with people
anymore you're more observed than you
can't be the observer and maybe that's
why it becomes hard too yeah i wrote
myself out of the narrative
still
wherever you go people are like oh
there's billy joel and that kind of
ruins the moment you can't go out and
observe anyone i can't be the fly on the
wall anymore no
um
my observations of of life
are in a from a bubble look i i
recognize i've been very fortunate in my
life i live in this rock star bubble i
do right yeah i i have friends who don't
but
uh it's
it's not something i would write about
anymore um
it's not as interesting to me as that
other kind of life was
uh i i like my life i enjoy my life but
that has nothing to do with like the
rest of the world anymore